Matthews with us in Salt Lake City hi
Matthew how are you hi Dave thanks for
taking my call
sure what's up in your world so I went
to medical school and now I'm three
years out of residency and enjoying the
debt burden that goes along with going
to medical school and kind of trying to
deal with that and establishing life
after training and I've got a great job
and a great practice and cool how do you
make they make about five hundred
thousand a year
good you got a great big income
congratulations
so I'm really glad I cam s did you make
I owe about three hundred and fifty
thousand okay I'll pay that off this
year well I hope so um well here's the
well two years is what I'm looking at
that'll work you know what taxes that's
about right
yeah the taxes are kind of what killing
me that's my question
comes in and that right now because of
the tax burden I've been paying into my
group's pension plan to kind of offset
some of the loss that comes with my
income I wouldn't do i wouldn't be you
wouldn't know you don't have a hundred
percent tax bracket
dadgum there it but you don't have a
hundred percent tax bracket so you're
putting hundred cent dollars in there
and it's saving you taxes I want you to
do that later but right now you need to
clean up this 350 I would stop doing
anything I'm doing anything until I get
this 350 cleaned up and to completely
focus on it obviously you got paid your
taxes but uh ya know I'm gonna stop
doing all investing I stopped doing all
retirement savings everything that we
get dead cleaned up in baby step two and
you're in an unusual baby step two but
you have an unusual income thank
goodness yeah so even even though I
guess I just I guess I haven't thought
about that way because I feel like
there's the money I'd make on the
investment starting this late in my
investing if I were still able to pay it
off over the course of you know the year
two years the benefit of the time that
I've already lost and saving for
retirement
oh dude you make $500,000 a year you're
gonna be okay yeah you need to clean up
this mess because here's the thing your
peers doctors are there an unusual breed
in that they're fabulously intelligent
and notoriously stupid with money right
with money here and so you know you just
have to not listen to anything anything
so you know don't don't take their
investment advice for your sakes
yeah just let's get the mess cleaned up
because here's the thing if your house
is paid for your student loans are paid
off
you got no payments anywhere you're
making a happen me in the area yeah you
load that pension up you load up a bunch
of other stuff and in 20 minutes you're
a multi-millionaire you can be fine okay
fine but your shortest path to stability
and prosperous times and in down times
your shortest path to wealth in
prosperous times and in down times get
added as no dad it just changes it
changes the way you feel when you go to
work in the morning sure yeah and would
so I have a couple loans that are you
know different interest rates one of
them I know you you talk about paying
off the lower balance first to get the
ball rolling I feel like I've got a ball
rolling and I've got some bigger
balances that you know the interest on
them is quite high and so I was thinking
maybe I'd attack though what is the what
is the interest rate five I have one
that's five point one two five and
another that's five percent okay and the
lower bound the lower interest rates are
three point five and so this works so
the spread is two percent if that were
true on two hundred thousand dollars
that would be a four thousand dollar
swing so it's pretty insignificant now
compared to three hundred fifty grand a
significant thing is your dedication
that you used to get through 16 18 years
of school to become the high income
earner that you are if you will take
that set of emotional maturity that you
have the ability to delay pleasure to
win and if you will apply the
that is your X game that's what takes
this get out of debt that that's your
that's your secret sauce dude and you've
already captured what most people never
capture in their life and that's the
ability to live like no one else so that
later you can live and give like no one
else you proved that by the track of
study that you did and that's why I
never ever say a doctor makes too much I
will never tell you you're overpaid at
five hundred thousand because you pay a
price that nobody else would pay to get
to be where you are you earn thank you
the right to get paid this money and so
I'm completely on your team use that
same emotional x-factor and that's more
important than the four thousand dollar
savings if you want to mix it up a
little bit to mix it up but be done in
two years yeah okay
yeah that's my goal and according to our
budget if things just hold you know the
way they are and our plan and there will
be will be out it feels so good now and
make sure that I wanna make sure our
listeners hear this okay change screwing
around the interest rate here it changed
though it equation four thousand dollars
out of three hundred fifty thousand
dollars so you don't have a four
thousand dollar problem you got a 300 mm
lotta problem so you hit it with three
and fifty thousand dollars solutions and
moving the interest rate around is not
it's it's a it's what does that turns
out to be one percent of the solution
ninety-nine percent of the solution
isn't a math you and five hundred
thousand dollar income that's your
solution
thank God you've got the income to go
with this man out right I know I feel
very blessed very blessed what field of
study I mean what field of practice
all right I'm an anesthesiologist of
course you're it's a bit I was more
nervous to talk on the radio than I was
that you know save a life in the
operating room bad bad that's that's
it's one of the bits one of the best
fields of study because this is you guys
get paid so well well I'm so proud of
you man okay now you clean it up and I
want to hear from you and you're dead
free all right hey thanks for all you do
I appreciate it a man be good open
phones a triple eight eight two five
five two two five yeah you're going to
stick a needle in my spine and I want
you to be under trained and underpaid no
I don't know I don't I don't want have
at all from somebody that's underpaid
and under trained I hope you make a
million dollars a year think people
think you people who think you're not
supposed to make money oh my goodness
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]